a neighboring concept of that is
conspiracy theories
which is i don't think they're
neighboring at all
well let me let me give myself a naive
perspective maybe you can educate me on
this from my perspective
conspiracy theories are these
constructs of ideas that go deeper and
deeper and deeper
into creating
worlds where there's uh
powerful pedophiles controlling things
like these uh very sophisticated
models of the world that you know in
part might be true
but in large part i would say are are
figments of imagination that become
really useful constructs and
self-reinforcing
self-reinforcing for then feeding
like empowering the trolls
to attack the uh powerful
the conventionally powerful i i don't
think that that's a function conspiracy
theories now let's talk about conspiracy
theories because one of my quotes is you
take one red pill not the whole bottle
this concept that everything in life
is at the function of a small cadre of
individuals
would be for many people reassuring
because as bad as it looks
you know they whoever they are it's
usually the jews
aren't going to let it get that bad that
they will pull back or
the the black pill is that they aren't
intentionally
trying to destroy everything and there's
nothing we can do and we're doomed and
there's an amazing book by arthur
hermann called the idea of decline
western history i
it's one of my top 10 books where he
goes through every 20 years how there's
a different population that say
it's the end the world here's the proof
and very often the proof is something
that is
kind of self-fulfilling where there's no
it's not falsifiable and we both have to
think of ways to falsify our claims from
earlier
yeah so it is a big danger
it's a big danger online because very
quickly if someone
who you thought was good but now is bad
on one aspect well they're controlled
opposition
or they've been uh taken over or they've
been kind of uh
appropriated by the bad people whoever
those bad people would be
um i don't know that i have a good
answer for this
i don't think it's as pervasive as
people think
the number of people who believe
conspiracy theory right the i mean and
also conspiracy theory is a term used
to dismiss ideas that have some currency
the constitutional convention was a
conspiracy
uh the founding fathers got together
secretly under sword of secrecy in
philadelphia said we're throwing out the
articles confederation we're making your
government right yeah yeah
and luther martin left and he told
everyone this is a conspiracy and
they're like yeah whatever luther morgan
so and jeffrey epstein was a conspiracy
harvey weinstein was a conspiracy bill
cosby the conspiracy they all knew
they didn't care uh communist
infiltration america there's a great
book by
eugene lyons called the red decade they
all knew they
every atrocity that was done under
stalinism was
excused in the west and if you didn't
believe it oh you've got this crazy
anti-russian conspiracy so
it's a term that is weaponized uh in a
negative sense but that does not all
imply that it does not have very
negative real life
consequences because it's kind of a cult
of one
right like i'm at home on my computer i
bet into this ideology
anyone who doesn't agree with me they're
blind
they're oblivious mom and dad my friends
you don't get it
we were warned about people like you and
i think there's a very heavy correlation
amount of psychiatrists of course
between that and certain types of mild
mental illness like uh you know some
kind of paranoid schizophrenia things
like that because
after a certain point if everything is a
function this conspiracy it's it's
there's no randomness or beauty in life
yeah i mean
i don't know if you can say anything
interesting about it in the way of
advice
of how to take a step into conspiracy
theory world without completely going
like diving deep
because it seems like that's what
happens people can't
look at jeffrey epstein i can tell you
what the device i'd have
seriously and rigorously without going
because you can look at jeffrey epstein
and say there's a deeper
thing you can always go deeper right
it's like jeffrey epstein was just the
tool
of the the lizard people and the lizard
people are
well they say satanists say in this case
and somehow recently very popular
pedophiles somehow always involved
i'm not understanding any of that i
legitimately i say this both humorously
and seriously i need to look into it
and i guess the bigger question i'm
asking how does a serious human being
uh somebody with a position at a
respectable university
like look at a conspiracy theory and
look into it when i
look at somebody like jeffrey epstein
who had a role at mit
yeah oh yeah and i and i think
i'm not happy personally
i didn't i wasn't there when jeffrey
epstein was there i'm not happy with the
behavior of people
now about jeffrey epstein about the
bureaucracy
and the everybody's trying to keep quiet
hoping it blows over
without really looking into any like
looking in a
deep philosophical way of like how do we
let this human being
be among us can i give you a better
example sure that
that is kind of conspiratorial the
speaker of the house
the longest serving republican speaker
of the house dennis hastert was a
pedophile
he went to jail the democrats don't
throw this in the republicans faces
every five minutes
not even democratic activists i find
that very very odd
and not what i would predict now i'm not
saying there's some kind of conspiracy
but when it comes to things like sexual
predation which is something that
i'm very very concerned about i'm an
uncle now my sister just had her second
kid recently he's adorable
it's something that i don't understand
if it feels as if there's a lot of
people who want this to all go away
now i think it's also because we don't
have the vocabulary and framework to
discuss it
because when you start talking about
things like children these kind of
issues
we want to believe it's all crap because
it's for those of us who aren't in this
kind of mindset the idea
that this happens to kids and happens
frequently is something so horrible
that we it's just like i don't even want
to hear it and that does these children
and adult survivors an enormous
disservice
so i don't know that i have any
particular insight on this but see like
how do you
i mean the catholic church again there's
all these topics that
public school teachers are far more
proportionally federer's the children of
the catholic church
i mean i don't know what i you're right
you're right um perhaps some
uh i've been you know reading a lot
about
stalin and hitler yeah somehow it's more
comforting
yeah like to be here and then and then
and then
the atrocities that are happening now
it's a little bit more difficult because
there was a new york times article
interrupted where they were had a people
tracking down child pornography
and i think the article said they didn't
have enough people just to cover the
uh videotapes of infants being raped and
we can even wrap our heads around like
reading lolita like okay she's 14
12 okay it's still a female an infant
it's it's something that
again like with the stalin example we
sat down here for a hundred years we
would never think of something like this
think of in a sexual context it makes no
sense
yeah um so and the fact that this is
international okay we eliminated
completely in america
well then they're gonna go find this
there's infants all over the world
there's video cameras all over the world
so then it has to become a conspiracy
because i
someone has to film it i'm filming it
you're buying it your kid
it is literally a conspiratorial not in
the sense of like a mafia conspiracy or
some government illuminati but there is
our networks
designed to produce this product see
but like what i'm i'm trying to do
now and part of the one of the nice
things with like a podcast and other
things i'm involved with
is i'm removing myself from having any
kind of boss
so i can do whatever yes it's oh it's so
it's so wonderful that just happened to
me it's it's the most wonderful thing
ever
uh so i could do i can actually in
moderation
consider like look into stuff careful
though i was going to write a book about
this and people pointed out
you should want to do this research
because if you start googling around for
this kind of stuff it's on your computer
oh in that sense yeah i'm more concerned
about
you know it's the nietzsche thing
looking into the abyss like you want to
be very
yeah i believe i can do this kind of
thing in moderation without slipping
oh yes into the depths of course i think
that's in that's intelligence that's uh
like i recently quote unquote looked
into like
the ufo community the um
extraterrestrial
whatever community i think it always
frustrated me
that the scientific community like
rolled their eyes at all the ufo
sightings all that kind of stuff
even though there could be fascinating
beautiful physical fun up like
first of all there could be like
lightning or the ball lightning right
that's at the very basic level is a
fascinating thing
and also it could be
something like i mean i don't know but
this could be something interesting
like worth looking into my grandfather
was an air traffic controller back in
the soviet union
and he said we saw this stuff all the
time these are planes that were not
moving or
whatever things that were not moving
according to anything we knew about
so it's absolutely real he's not some
jerk with an iphone in his backyard
this is a military professional
who understood technology who knew where
the secret bases were yeah so if he's
telling me
it's something doesn't mean it's
martians but he's telling me there's
something there and there are many
examples of
of these like military people these
aren't some laymen who sees the story
people yeah and and so it's you you can
dismiss
when you're talking about professionals
who around aircraft all the time who are
familiar with aircraft at the heights
levels
and they're seeing things that they
can't explain it's they're clearly not
stupid and they're clearly not under
form so by
there's different ways to dismiss idea
for example
i um you were saying that trolling is a
good mechanism
i'm against that but i'm not dismissing
it by
like rolling my eyes i'm considering
legitimately that you're way smarter
than me
and you understand the world better than
me like i'm allow myself to consider
that possibility and thinking about it
like
maybe that's true like seriously
considering it that's what
that's i feel the way people should
approach
intelligent people serious quote-unquote
people scientists should approach
conspiracy theories like look at
it carefully you know is first of all is
it possible that the earth is flat
it's not trivial to show that the earth
is not flat
it's a very good exercise you should go
through it yes but once you go through
it you
realize that uh based on
a lot of data and a lot of evidence and
there's a lot of different experiments
you could do yourself actually
to show that the earth is not flat okay
the same kind of process can be taken
for a lot of different conspiracy
theories and it's helpful
and without slipping into the depths of
of lizard people running everything
that's where i i i've now listened to
two episodes
of um of alex jones's show
because he goes crazy
deep into um
into different kind of world views that
i was not familiar with right
and i don't know what to make of it i
mean the reason i've been listening to
it is because
um there's been a lot of discussions
about platforming of different people
and i've been thinking about what does
censorship mean
i've been thinking about it whether
because joe rogan uh
said he's gonna have alex on again
and then i enjoyed it as a fan just the
entertainment of it
but then i actually listened to alex
and i was thinking is this human being
dangerous for the world
like is the ideas he's saying dangerous
for the world i'm more concerned with
the russian conspiracy that we had for
three years
and the claim that our election was not
legitimate and that everyone in the
trump white house is a student putin
and the people who said this had no
consequences for this alex jones doesn't
have the respect that they do
uh these are both areas of concern for
me but he he might if there's
if he's given more platforms so like the
the the the people who've
and i'd be curious if i'm also a little
bit
i don't know what to think about the
idea that russians hacked the election
it seems too easily accepted in the
mainstream media hillary clinton said
that how they did it was they had ads
on the dark web now you and i both know
what the dark web is
so the possibility of ads in the dark
web having an influence
from a proportional influence on the
election is literally zero
perhaps i should look into it more
carefully but i've found very little
good
data on exactly
what did the russians do to hack
elections like
like technically speaking what are we
talking about here like
as opposed to these kind of weird like
the best thing there's a couple books
and
like reporting on like farms
like control farms troll farms but
let's see the data like how many
exactly what are we talking about like
what were they doing
relative not just like some anecdotal
discussions
of but like relative to the bigger
the size of facebook like if there's a
few
people several hundred say the posting
different
political things on facebook relative to
the full size of facebook let's look at
the full size like right
like a scientist the actual impact like
the because it's
fascinating the social dynamics of viral
information
of videos when when uh donald trump
retweets something
i think that's understudied the effect
of that
uh like he retweeted
a clip with joe rogan on um with and
mike tyson
where mike tyson says that he finds
fighting orgasmic
i don't understand that but they'd be
fascinating to think like what is the
ripple effect on the social
uh dynamic of our society from
retweeting a clip about mike ty what's
your favorite um
um trump tweet i
i tuned the model a long time ago
unfortunately
i have um it's the this goes to the
you and i have a different relationship
with donald trump you appreciate the art
of trolling non-sexual non-sexual yeah
so
i i tend to prefer uh bill clinton he's
more my type no i'm just kidding uh i
don't know
you don't like that consent stuff no
because no
uh no you appreciate the art form of
trolling and and uh
donald trump is is a a master he's the
da vinci of trolling so
i tend to think that trolling is
ultimately destructive for society
and then donald trump takes nothing
seriously he's playing a game he's
making a game out of everything takes a
lot of things seriously i think he's
very committed to
international peace i say i i shouldn't
speak so strongly i think
i think he takes actually yes a lot of
things seriously i meant
on twitter and the game of politics
yeah he is um
[Music]
he only takes irreverently yeah yeah and
um i appreciate it i just
would like to focus on like genuine real
expressions of humanity especially
positive
well this is my love this is my favorite
tweet my fans got it
laser etched and put in a block of
lucite for me
and he said every time i speak of the
losers and haters
i do so with great affection they cannot
help the fact that they were born [ __ ]
up
that's an actual trump tweet it's my
favorite one
and that's kind of nice that's love
that's love that's kind of not affection
that i mean exclamation point
even
um i broke lex what is love
yeah the sparks are flying but uh i have
to
kind of analyze that from a like a
literary perspective but
it seems like there's love in there like
a little bit like it's
a little bit light-hearted because he's
saying even when i'm going after them
don't take it so seriously yeah
that's that's nice it is nice
acknowledging the game of it that's yes
that's nice
uh he's not always sometimes he's very
very vicious
yeah very vicious he's done things that
i i can tell you about that i'm like
this is a bad person
you